Connor just give us a little bit of the
background to this case and why there's
been such a big political row about it
how does the justice system deal with
prisoners who self-identify as women and
that is something that the first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon has been
taking questions on in the last few
minutes this case centers around
messages being a dude is like stuck in a
prison with other guys for life in
prison and the next day you find out if
you just say you're a woman
you get access to [__] yo
but that happened though there's a guy
that there's a guy that that says he was
self-identified as a woman got into got
into the woman in jail got two is
pregnant yeah no no no that's not what
happened that's not what happened what
happened was a woman got other women
pregnant
I'm sorry you're right
I'm sorry you're absolutely right a
woman got women who have uteruses
pregnant that's what happened you're
right I remember reading that headline
and I just saw a woman gets women
pregnant and I just went bruh 2022 is a
while
I don't care how much this gender stuff
goes forward I just every time I see
these kind of I just laugh man gives
birth and I'm like what to a dookie like
no baby it's like oh my God stop a
double rapist uh who attacked two women
while they were known as Adam Graham a
number of years ago and they made their
decision to transition uh while awaiting
trial in that criminal case and they're
now known as Isla Bryson and they are
controversially being held in Scotland's
all-female prison Corinth and Veil and
the Sterling shirt area at the Scottish
conservatives that is that is better
than a good lawyer you found the
loophole bro what's up with these ladies
with Superman Jaws [__] doing all
this extra [__] bro because they want to
do this other extra [__] this has
nothing to do with trans people it's
people
this people
uh taking advantage of the loophole
sure but how do you know that
well that's a convenient thing you you
say you say that and maybe this is true
that some people will take advantage but
you can't have every criminal who's
trans happen to all of a sudden not be
trans anymore because you don't want it
to make you know bro bro
I can't be sure of that
okay so you don't know what it is no I
don't okay okay listen she she she says
who she is so use the right pronouns
that's what it is I never I never said
the opposite I will use the right
pronoun will you now [__]
[Laughter]
I'm sorry I just yeah it was frozen on
this shot and it just kind of [__] me
up you know yeah
will you now now we are told that Isla
Bryson is in segregation at this moment
in time is not within the general prison
population but that has not stopped the
questions and certainly the response
from Nicola sturgeon has been clear she
said I don't know how it's possible for
a rapist uh to be in a female prison
wait why not
what's issue if she's a woman then
thrown in that prison I've been told
this what if a woman or anybody feels
like they're a woman then they are a
woman that is the ideology you've been
sold to that's what that's what you
don't have to put on makeup no you don't
have to change the way you dress you
don't have to go through any gender
reassignment surgery no if you say then
you are
that is the barometer you cannot take
that away from this person just because
they've done criminal activities you get
what I'm trying to say I get you so for
me there's incongruence there with this
whole thing and it's a [__] up thing
to say but if you really believe in this
whole transgender stuff the way that
they sell it then you have to say that
this person belongs in a woman's prison
well a person is a dangerous place
nobody cares about whenever there's a
man in danger in a danger in in a male
in a male prison no matter what they did
whatever what not it is a dangerous
place no matter what basically actually
the punishment of going to prison is a
bit that it is dangerous
and you don't have like all your Lively
your livelihood and all all your your
yeah so the one of the premise of the
prison is that it's that let's be honest
okay so whenever you wear other people
that are like criminals it is going to
be dangerous so
if you like you said and not pretty
feisty Exchange in Edinburgh in the last
few minutes described Isla Bryson as a
beast and they said that Isla Bryson
should not be kept in that women's
environment where other women are being
incarcerated at the moment I will say
some trans women look like their idea of
Womanhood is performative
like they go to that 90s hello Barbie
look when they want to become women or
quote-unquote they go to the most
stereotypically overly feminine
unrealistic overly glamorized look when
I see something whenever I see that I'm
like
drag
I don't know what it is it's just
something I noticed was like some part
of transness also means reinforcing
gender stereotypes to the degree yeah
rough do you want to truth you wanna
really think and this is something I
just came to the realization this whole
like idea of like gender expression and
all this other stuff I don't give a [__]
it's whatever I don't but listen for me
the whole idea of gender has always been
just linked to biology that's how I've
always used it functionally right the
when I take the idea that a woman is a
woman what I'm saying in that moment is
like she generally on average is going
to be physically smaller than men not as
strong as men capable of giving birth
you know ass and titties okay imma look
at those stuff that's always been the
functionality oh well I express like
listen when I say women what I say like
that is I don't people who Express as we
would have biological females
understanding so for me the idea of
Womanhood and feel on this have always
been interchangeable all this talk about
well the outfits I wear and the kind of
name like I don't give a [__] about none
of that [__] when I think about what a
woman is so you ask me from like when I
think of women's sports I don't think
about gender expression I just think
about their biology the old use of women
my whole life has just been for people
who are females so for me the two words
are pretty much the same thing to be
honest with you bless me that was
something that Charities were saying
over the course of the last few days and
quite crucially Nicholas sturgeon was
clear that Isla Bryson will not continue
to be incarcerated in a women's prison
here in Scotland will not continue to be
housed at Corinth and Vale you know
what's [__] up
if she shows up to a man's prison
looking like that dangerous uh what she
did to other women is about to be done
to her I wonder I wonder as a means of
survival how quick do you think she
about to change up her look when she
found out she going to the dudes prison
oh quick things yeah yeah I'm getting
face tattoos I'm buzzing my hair cut
quick things somebody tried to call me
Ela again I'm like sorry it's Elijah or
something new I'd be getting my voice
even deeper I even played none of that
Scotland's all female at prison it's
unclear I think at this stage exactly
where Isla Bryson will go and of course
it opens up further questions about what
happens with the rest of Scotland's Tran
uh population is that her before face
tattoos and [__]
thank you
you said is that far before I think
that's her before she goes to the male
prison as soon as she found out what the
judge said she said
where's the umbrella where is it yeah
all of a sudden she got face tattoos
uh we're just showing you an image here
of Adam Graham who carried out these
attacks when they were known as Adam
Graham there are 15 trans people in
Scotland's prisons at this stage to put
that in context there's a wider
population of around 7 000 prisoners now
the Scottish prison service has been
cleared throughout the course of this
that they make these decisions on where
each and every prisoner should be held
on a case-by-case basis a little bit
dicey it sounds like
and it ended up to just say your trains
you won't have to do some prove it in
which case I think that's [__] up yeah
it is I think that's [__] you don't
make you know you don't make no proofing
nowhere
that's what I said earlier whenever you
said no no whenever you say it would a
person has to say that if they feel like
they express it in a certain way they
don't have to do nothing they just have
no posts are pre-op doesn't matter and
now and out and I said and they don't
have to prove it yeah and now you do
because if you think about it gender
reassignment surgery is actually pretty
expensive it's not accessible to a lot
of poor trans people so someone feels
like they're trans and therefore they
want to go through that transition them
not having access to all that surgery
stuff shouldn't recruit them based off
the ideology you subscribe to whenever
you say because of that case when you
say well not people are gonna have to
prove it now now you are actually
um being
um you discriminate against trans people
yep that's what you're doing right now
in order to be shared against the
discrimination
in order to be fair
because of a transverse they need to
discriminate trans people
22. firstly in general any prisoner who
poses a risk of sexual offending is
segregated from other prisoners
including during any period of risk
assessment secondly there is no
automatic right for a trans woman
convicted of a crime to serve their
sentence in a female prison even if they
have a gender recognition certificate
every case is subject to rigorous
individual risk assessment and what this
says and I'm gonna just because it is
all like blah blah blah basically what
she said is just because you're serious
trans woman doesn't mean it's true
and
trans women are women with an asterisk
ain't that what I said in the beginning
because a woman would never have to go
through this
trans women do because even though they
subscribe to this ideology for clout
purposes the truth or who knows I
actually don't know why they subscribe
to this ideology but even though they
claim to the reality is they're willing
to rescind that person's Womanhood based
off whatever criteria they didn't fit
and I'm gonna be honest if you feel like
gender is an internal thing which nobody
on the outside can see we have to
therefore believe what they're doing is
essentially denying that
that idea that's what they're doing as I
understand and that's what I said in the
beginning no when I said well you know
that's not a translator and then they
doing that if you're asking me
personally what I think I have no
problem with this stuff because I don't
believe that trans women should be if it
was prisons but I'm also not an idiot if
someone is a trans woman and they're
being sent to a males person like that
ain't a good existence either I think
it's very similar to women's sports well
I think there's very few
um good solutions to this problem
and I also want you to appreciate
throughout all of this
almost like a forgotten child we don't
even know what happened to trans men who
thank you for watching today's video let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below
you know it's like it's like when my
family's traveling and then they go like
10 hours to like some Northern camping
areas yeah and then they realize they
forgot one of their children yeah like
the home alone I think who Kevin